[Music]
we kept a lot of it from you the
Kardashians tackled their toughest
topics on Sunday night's midseason
finale of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians the women underwent media
training we all have been doing media
interviews for a decade and we've never
had media training and that's usually
one of the first things that you do when
you start off in this business their
teachers set up mock interviews and went
for the families most difficult issues
including asking Kris Jenner to address
whether she knew her one-time husband
wanted to transition more than half of
the marriage it was like a
picture-perfect two people in love
having kids doing this doing that travel
so excited like I wouldn't have seen
that truth in a gazillion years people's
truths at the end the truth is so
different than in the beginning we kept
a lot of it from you like we were
there's things that happened that I that
they didn't tell me I'm not resentful
about it it just makes me really sad
her recent life experiences has just
made her more insecure and not really
confident kris has definitely dealt with
her ups and downs but when we spoke to
her in October how she was all about
keeping perspective we get to work
together every single day I say that
every time I do an interview but it is
true because I think that's what you
know makes us so close
we're together I have my crew here today
filming Keeping Up with the Kardashians
so we're never without our family we
tended family